So, hopefully you're able to see the most likely
inheritance pattern is autosomal and dominant. Now, what's the
reason for this? An autosomal inheritance pattern means that
the alleles affecting the trait are on the autosomes, not
the sex chromosomes. So, we should see both males
and females affected fairly equally. So, we know it's not
sex linked because we see that in our pedigree.
We also know it's not maternal, because maternal means it's
inherited through the mitochondria. So the mother would pass it
on to all of her children, and that's not in
fact what we see here. Now what about dominant? Well,
it can be recessive, it most likely isn't recessive because recessive
traits, affected children come from unaffected parents which is not
what we see here. And we also expect the trait to
skip generations which we don't see. When it's dominant we
expect to see the trait in every generation, and affected parents
give rise to affected children.